the Joe Rogan experience yeah the the
incremental progress that we achieve as
a civilization is it's amazing but also
so frustratingly slow that no one I mean
no one I've ever talked to thinks
there's gonna be a moment in our
lifetime where there's no war no one no
one thinks is gonna be a moment in our
lifetime with there's no murder no one
thinks there's gonna be a moment in our
lifetime where there's no rape where we
just we just figure it out like I'm
pretty confident if it was just the
three of us forever no one would rape
anybody
no one murders the three of us sure
because I'm probably the victim here I'm
saying like what what number of people
have how how many people do they have to
be yeah before one of those things
becomes possibility yeah but what if you
have a group of close friends a group of
group of close friends who are good
communicators and good honest healthy
friendly people can live together and
yeah you know whatever issues you might
have with someone not doing the dishes
or someone forgetting to put back your
lawn mower or whatever the [ __ ] it is
you could work that out it's no deal
like what is what's the number of people
150 okay that's Dunbar's know right yeah
I'm sure you've heard about that yeah I
mean that might really be it that might
really be what we're programmed for
that's what hunter-gatherer that's where
hunter-gatherer groups always splinter
yeah or they never get beyond that and I
think that's why because you know a
hunter-gatherer group which is
egalitarian and sharing and cooperative
and all that by necessity right because
that's how our ancestors survived is by
taking care of each other mitigating
risk you need reputational damage and if
everyone doesn't know everyone
reputational damage is no longer
effective so if you let's say you go and
you're you're a good hunter and you kill
an antelope and then you don't share it
and you just keep it for yourself that's
not gonna go over real well with a
hunter-gatherer group yeah you're gonna
be ridiculed chastise may be expelled
from the group maybe have a hunting
accident
and die because that hoarding selfish
behavior
is extremely taboo in a hunter-gatherer
society where as you know you look at
our society where reputational damage is
no longer functional
outside of your group of friends as long
as you're good to your friends your
golfing buddies you can screw the rest
of the world you can not pay your
contractors for years and become
president right you know yeah everyone
in New York I worked in real estate in
New York in the 80s everyone knew who
that guy was and what he was up to and
they couldn't trust him he was full of
[ __ ] and they ripped everybody off and
but that's how business works in New
York even the the company I was working
for is really interesting to see how
your leverage increased when you owed
somebody a lot of money you know as
there's that truism if you have someone
five bucks you have a problem with you
owe them a million bucks they have a
problem you know I really see that but
yeah I think it's 150 is is the cutoff
for how many people we can keep track I
think
Dunbar's numbers proved to be pretty
accurate well it seems to be what we
what we evolved to sort of be accustomed
to right yeah that's the well that's not
me Oh cortex that's you know Dunbar was
looking at the the brain anatomy of
different primates and by looking at the
proportion of a neocortex to the rest of
the brain he predicted the maximum
social size of those primates of each of
the species and that's how he came to
the estimate of 154 humans and then they
went and looked at people that they did
you know data collection that's so crazy
yeah they can do the physical size of
something like that that there's a
direct correlation like the direct
correlation between the size of primates
testicles and the amount of promiscuous
females in the area you've read sex is
done
[Laughter]
[Applause]